avez-vous fait bon voyage pour venir
jusqu'ici emprunter nos réseaux urbains
qu'il soit routier de transport en
commun de télécommunications ou
électrique n'est pas toujours une partie
de plaisir surtout quand il s'agit de
venir dans des contrées lointaines comme
saclay pourtant aujourd'hui ensemble
nous allons voir que les balades
effectué par les hommes dans ces réseaux
urbains peuvent être l'occasion d'un jeu
en un sens que je vais vous définir pour
jouer dans ces réseaux urbains
il faut commencer par avoir des joueurs
et là je me permets un postulat osé tout
homme n'est fondamentalement joueurs
c'est un des rôles de la société et de
certains de ces chercheurs un petit peu
excentrique de donner ce goût du jeu et
de l'entretenir de montrer la vie sous
une forme ludique et d'y fixer de bonnes
règles pour arriver à une solution
collective efficace pour que les hommes
ne fassent pas de ces réseaux urbains le
lieu d'une promenade purement
individuelle et là vous vous dites
sûrement déjà mais comment at il pu en
arriver là
prat à tel point à côté de la plaque
n'at-il pas pris le bus 80 06 pour venir
jusqu'ici
revenons à mes racines
pour comprendre ce virus du jeu à 10 12
ans bien au chaud sous la couette et
greer d'une faible lampe de chevet je
relisais un magazine trouvé je ne sais
où et aux noms évocateurs vasaloppet
transjurassienne ces noms ne vous dit
sûrement rien en fait j'espère pour vous
il s'agit de cours de ski de fond dans
le froid sous la neige le faut parcourir
jusqu'à une centaine de kilomètres vous
l'avez compris dans mon cas le virus du
jeu s'est construit autour du sport en
particulier autour de grands défis
sportifs ces défis dans lesquelles les
limites personnelles ne sont dépassées
que grâce à un élan et un soutien
collectif
dix ans plus tard naturellement je me
retrouve seul au départ d'une course nom
tout aussi mythique la saintélyon
je suis donc là entouré de charmants
camarades avec une lampe frontale parce
qu'en plus ça joue de nuit le principe
est simple je vous le rappelle on part
de saint-etienne et on arrive à lyon
avec pour seuls alliés ses baskets et
donc la lampe frontale
je suis donc sur ses mines de départ
avec ma lampe -10 degrés et un t-shirt
bon mais j'arrête là la description de
mon propre virus du jeu je suis sûr que
chacun d'entre vous
sous une forme personnelle détient en
lui cette fibre joueuses une fibre
joyeuse lorsqu'on regarde le
déchaînement des foules avec pokémon go
les forces vives de la nation sur leur
portable
jouant le matin en allant au travail on
ne doute pas de ses fibres joyeuse
joueuses d'ailleurs aussi mais arriver
là qu'en fait tout ce que je vous
propose aujourd'hui et que je vis dans
mes développe en mathématiques mais
aussi dans mes défi sportif c'est de
faire de la vie dans nos réseaux urbains
un jeu bon là il vous manque sûrement un
truc c'est quoi un jeu alors sans entrer
dans des développements mathématiques
trop difficile
je vous donner une définition théorique
de ski un jeu ça commence par un
ensemble de joueurs que nous sommes tous
ensuite ce sont des actions à
disposition de chacun de ses joueurs
et enfin c'est un coup pour tous les
joueurs et dans ce coup vous voyez
intervenir deux dimensions d'une part
une dimension individuelle
elle ne dépend que de notre propre
action d'autre part une dimension
collective
elle dépend toujours de notre propre
action mais aussi de l'action de tous
les joueurs qui nous entoure ne passe
coordonnées dans les réseaux urbains
modernes c'est aller au devant tous
ensemble de coûts collectifs important
le temps passé sur la route la pollution
le bruit bon mais observez un petit peu
plus cette formule magique et notamment
le paramètre alpha au magnifique alpha
dans les jeux urbains l'alpha c'est la
vie pour le comprendre
imaginons que le coût collectif
représente la pollution dans nos villes
et le coût individuel une notion de
confort et de
temps passé lorsque nous nous parcourons
seville fixé alpha égal zéro c'est
ouvrir un boulevard la dimension
individuelle et aux 4,4 sur les artères
parisiennes soit dit en passant
fixé au contraire alpha égale plus
l'infini c'est pousser dans le sens de
la dimension collective choix difficile
qui est celui de alpha et qui cache des
inégalités criantes
certaines personnes au dessus de la
mêlée ont la possibilité de se
soustraire un alpha fixé par la
puissance publique
d'autres personnes ne peuvent le
contourner mais laissons là ces débats
politiques et maintenant je vais honorer
la promesse que je vous ai faite vous
montrer que les balades dans nos réseaux
urbains modernes peuvent être miss mise
sous la forme d'un jeu au sens que je
viens de vous définir
vous êtes venu à saclay vous avez vu sa
clé dans quelques heures il va falloir
repartir vous propose de faire le trajet
du retour avec moi de manière ludique
comme tout bon travailleur à saclay
lorsque vous sortirez si vous n'avez pas
de voiture pas de chance vous avez deux
options
vous pouvez prendre une navette
interentreprises qui vous mènera à via
le réseau routier directement porte
d'orléans
ou alors vous tentez les transports en
commun avec le bus 86 91 06 pardon puis
le rer vers paris
le travailleur de fin de journée n'est
pas fou il veut rentrer au plus vite
chez lui il sort donc son magnifique
smartphone effectué deux recherches
l'une d'entre elles pour estimer combien
de temps ils mettraient pour les porte
d'orléans voiture donc en navette
l'autre recherche pour le même
itinéraire effectué en transport en
commun
généralement il choisit l'option la plus
rapide
là vous vous dites sûrement qu'il s'agit
d'un choix purement individuelle mais
vous n'avez pas encore le virus du jeu
laissez-moi vous contaminer en fait
cette décision dépend bien sûr de tous
les choix qui ont été faits par les
personnes parties avant vous si
malheureusement elles ont pris
l'itinéraire que vous comptiez emprunter
il va y avoir des gros bouchons il faut
interagir
une façon de faire pour interagir et de
voir cette situation comme un jeu les
règles du jeu sont alors défini par un
opérateur urbain qui est maître du jeu
mais aussi arbitre nous allons le voir
bon mais maintenant supposons que nous
avons pris la navette en chemin très
rapidement nous allons sûrement tombé
sur ce panneau ce panneau c'est un
concentré de théorie des jeux imaginés
l'opérateur qui joue avec les deux
valeurs de temps de trajet sur ce
panneau par un simple changement de
valeur il peut faire perdre ou gagner
quelques minutes à des milliers de
franciliens rentrant chez eux
pressé il peut bien sûr dire la vérité
annoncé les temps de trajet réel mais
alors tous les gens vont se ruer sur
l'option la plus courte
naturellement quelques instants plus
tard un bouchon coordination nécessaire
bon aux etats unis ils font d'autres
choix il montre les tarifs pour
emprunter les voies plus de temps de
trajet là le choix public est
complètement différent en france la
valeur du temps passé sur la route est
de 10 euros par heure pour tous les
automobilistes français c'est le même
alpha aux états unis chaque personne
peut choisir son alfa si on a les moyens
on paie on prend la voie express et on
ne vit pas les coûts collectifs
est ce vraiment le jeu que l'on veut
jouer bon d'autres solutions existent
je vous rassure notamment covoiturer
alors là souvent des voies sont
réservées aux voitures bien remplie au
moins deux personnes à bord
mais là attention méfions nous rappelez
vous les hommes sont très joueurs
parfois tellement joueurs qu'ils en
deviennent tricheurs jusqu'à mettre
leurs plus belles poupées gonflables à
la place de leurs chers covoitureurs sur
la place du passager et s'engouffrer
vaillamment sur la voie réservée aux
covoitureurs naturellement l'opérateur
urbain le shérif local se doit d'agir de
jouer son rôle d'arbitré
ma chère poupée vous êtes hors jeu mais
bon rappelez-vous nous sommes dans la
navette
nous arrivons à porte d'orléans terminus
tout le monde descend arrive le dernier
kilomètre souvent le plus long et la
dirigeons nous vers un système de vélos
en libre service
nous sommes à paris notre vélo s'appelle
vélib nouveau champ de bataille où les
décisions individuelles des hommes se
confrontent prendre un vélo rapidement
le déposer rapidement ce fut d'ailleurs
mon premier travail de chercheur
quelques mois imaginer les hommes
utilisant les vélib comme des joueurs
pour arriver un superbe théorème je le
remet aujourd'hui encore j'en suis tout
ému tellement il ne m'est d'aucune
utilité quand tous les soirs j'enfourche
un vélib et je veux rentrer chez moi au
plus vite
bon je retiens tout de même deux
messages le premier prouver l'existence
d'un équilibre c'est bien beau
mathématiquement mais à court terme
savait pas la collectivité deuxième
message ne pourront pas jouer face aux
décisions individuelles de tous nos
semblables
que ce soit le cas d'un réseau vélib ou
de tout autre réseau urbain il faut
trouver une bonne information moyenne
sur la situation de ces réseaux ici le
nombre moyen de personnes utiliseront
les stations bon mais ce soir nous
devons dépasser les limites
ce théorème n'est pas suffisant je les
fasse finissons à pied nous arrivons
chez moi devant la porte
je loue et avant monte les marches à
pied comme tous les soirs six étages
tout de même j'ouvre la boîte aux
lettres une facture de la copropriété
une note pour l'ascenseur nouveau coup
collectif partagé au sein de l'immeuble
et un nouvelle alfa lié à la valeur
disons-le étages à laquelle on habite
vous l'avez compris nouveau jeu les
règles sont simples nous partageons le
coût collectif de l'ascenseur
proportionnellement à l'étagé auquel
nous habitons chaque soir lorsque je
monte les marches l'ascenseur ne monte
pas je gagne donc de l'argent mais
chaque soir est ce que je découvre en
lisant cette facture lorsque je monte
les marches tous mes voisins gagne de
l'argent
je suis ravi bon mais nous sommes au
sixième devant ma porte je vous laisse
là je suis désolé je suis un petit peu
fatigué petit conseil au passage joue
avec excès comporte des risques mais bon
pour moi
azimut canapé hélas à peine assis une
petite voix lancinante dans ma tête
n'as tu pas oublié le jeu le plus
important je fonce à la porte bien sûr
entrer vous
les bienvenus une dernière partie en
effet ma thèse a proposé d'amener le jeu
dans un nouveau monde de le sortir de
ces applications traditionnelles place
au réseau électrique
pour expliquer ce nouveau jeu prendre
une tâche très simple il avait une
chemise demain c'est eddie hicks
je dois l'avait ma plus belle chemise à
l'ancienne je pourrais prendre cette
chemise la mettre dans le bac et appuyez
sur le bouton erreur ou plutôt peut
mieux faire
la jouer collectif dans le monde
électrique c'est ne pas oublier notre
enseignement du catéchisme électrique
pour ton prochain le réseau tu ne
détériorera pour sa santé une bonne
tension tu maintiendra pour notre
bonnaire et moyens de production non
polluants tu sollicitera oui mais et
alors
ma thèse a proposé de faire jouer des
consommations électriques dit flexible
entre elle effective au sens on peut les
décaler dans le temps la machine à laver
donc mais le véhicule électrique le
lave-vaisselle passe aussi ses
consommations flexible on joue un jeu
entre elles dans le quartier elles vont
entamer une discussion toutes les
machines à laver en trêve itérative mans
sur la base d'une information collective
dont j'ai montré la valeur
elles vont discuter tant qu'elles ne
sont pas toutes d'accord entre elles
la discussion continue heureusement
rassurez-vous très rapidement la
discussion s'arrête elles ont convergé
vers une d'ici une décision qui pour
chacune est stable individuellement et
bonne collectivement les meilleurs pour
notre système électrique
ainsi chacun d'entre nous détiendra une
partie de cette solution collective pour
un monde électrique meilleur et tout ça
depuis notre canapé rassurez vous met
alors au terme de ce long voyage
revenons tout de même sur mon postulat
fondamental sommes nous prennent montrer
joueurs dans ces réseaux urbains
nous l'avons vu en regardant les
panneaux sur l'a6 en pédalant vélib en
prenant l'ascenseur nous jouons déjà des
jeux sans le savoir
mais sommes-nous prêts à jouer aussi
avec nos consommations électriques pour
amener un petit élément de réponse je
vous propose une dernière balade montons
tous ensemble à montmartre est là depuis
les hauteurs spatiale de montmartre nous
voyons la terre illumine
et à cet instant comme dans la première
montée de la saintélyon que je me
retournais et que je voyais le ballet
des lampes frontales s'animer et que
cela me donnait une image de l'effort
collectif qui se jouer à cet instant des
auteurs spatiale de montmartre voir
cette multitude de lumières dans la
pénombre mondiale ce nombre potentiel de
joueurs me donne une grande lueur
d'espoir larbitre la vue oui les joueurs
sont prêts il siffle le coup d'envoi
ensemble gagnons cette nouvelle partie
merci
[Applaudissements]